welcome back to another gadget lab show
I am Michael colori and I'm Robby
Baldwin he's a new guy we're gonna start
off by having Robbie tell us a little
bit about what's going on with Google
and their latest hardware that's coming
down the road and then we're going to
bring on Nate and we're gonna talk about
a new product from Nike and we're going
to show you some headphones from 50 cent
the rapper more rapper headphones yes
you don't see that a lot you don't see
that a lot these uncharted territory
anyway let's start out with you telling
us what's going on with the big G so
Google is allegedly working on heads up
display glasses according to a report
from New York Times and 9to5 mac the
glasses should come out at the end of
the year and you'll be able to see
probably location-based information
there's no word on whether it'll have a
like a small screen in the corner or if
it'll be an overlay there seems to be
some some some discussion on which which
they'll go with so it could just be like
purely informational stuff you know
maybe like Google+ up I will said
twitter updates but my baby plus updates
or you know is it going to be more like
google goggles with or like Yelp
augmented reality things like that where
I like where do I eat and then it shows
you like the ratings of all the
restaurants and stuff yeah I think
people are hoping it's more augmented
reality like Google Goggles I'm just
having something in the corner does it
seem like I mean I wouldn't buy that
that's the it's not exciting enough to
break into the market some sort of
augmented reality would probably do a
lot better hands-free is kind of cool
that you can get like the same
information to be able to get off of an
android phone but without actually
having to take your phone out yeah and
but they want to add navigation to to
use your head so you would like nod your
head to swipe and they were saying that
people wouldn't notice that but I mean
look at me right now that's that's odd
and then if I look away
uh yeah what if your attention gets
diverted across the street or something
like that well right now we have that
thing where you know you can be talking
on your phone and walking down the
street and having a heated conversation
people don't know whether you're like on
a conference call or if you're just
mentally deranged yeah sort of an
extension of that so if you have a
nervous tics I have nervous tics with my
hands but if I had a nervous tic of my
head it'd be useless yeah is that or you
know you just be constantly scrolling in
different directions olives like oh oh
oh god where I how do I get back to
latitude so when what are they what are
they actually making the announcement
they're saying that it should ship by
the end of the year or announced by the
end of the year so maybe it I oh maybe
may your conference in many fingers
crossed everyone will have won and lost
what's the so if I did want to buy it
what are they would like what are they
gonna sell for so the price range is
anywhere from 250 to six hundred dollars
which is a pretty large price range so
okay about the same as like a good high
end phone yeah except stylish it must
look like those oakley like wrap around
yeah right they're gonna look
tremendously dorky and it's going to be
the segue of your face I bet you're
gonna see people walking around you'd be
like oh I got the google glasses what
they need to do is licensed it and let
people build it into into other glasses
engineers should not be designing
fashion and obsessions that way that I
feel who knows maybe they'll blow us all
away I have only nothing but high hopes
high hopes hope for the best looking up
looking at you google up next we've got
Nathan hi Nathan oh hi I couldn't help
noticing that strange and unusual thing
you're holding there in your hands what
is that you mean this Nike FuelBand so
what's it like is it a is it sort of
like a Fitbit like a body media that
kind of thing like an activity monitor
I'd say it's most comparable to a Fitbit
you put it on your wrist or possibly
your ankle if you're doing a lot of
cycling and your kind of what you wear
it around all day and it keeps track how
much you move it calculates how many
calories you're burning and it's all
based on a little accelerometer and
side and kind of the it gives you this
little bar along the top which you get
this little goal of a green LED and used
to kind of spend your whole day working
towards that a green LED that tells you
when you've scored enough points I see
so you just wear it it's a nerd and then
when you want to check your progress you
just press the button and it gives you
the little the little readout tells you
how much you've walked or whatever and
then later you plug it into your
computer and maybe you share it on
Facebook or on Twitter or there's also
an iphone app which we haven't yet got
the chance to play with so what do you
use the iphone app does that log your
meals for you as well as it have one of
those things that they like keeps track
of your calories and only not from what
I've seen it's more to give you kind of
a real time sink to to putting your data
into a nike+ system which allows you to
share it I see so this is this is
probably something that you know nike
has been working on for a while but I
mean this category has been pretty hot
for a couple of years now I mean
everybody's heard about the Fitbit at
this point sort of these devices that
you know are visible on you to remind
you to go the active yeah well we're
kind of seeing a trend in being able to
monitor how active and how fit you are
and and some of them some of them lean
more towards workout centric I would say
this one is more on kind of the reminder
end of the scale as in it's always with
you and you know it's just kind of like
you notice her on your wrist and you say
hey maybe I'll take the stairs hmm
that's a that's the same the same story
we get with all these things that we see
them when we're reminded I think it's
kind of this this one's kind of
interesting because it's not nearly as
ostentatious is like the the jawbone up
or you know some of the ones that like
actually attached here to the outside of
your arm you can see them if you're
wearing a t-shirt it is good looking and
I kind of wish that this that this
colorful display would just stay on all
the time um but it's also discreet you
know it's about the size and the shape
of one of those lance armstrong
bracelets yeah right except it's not
bright yellow it's not bright yellow
probably maybe they'll come out with and
they don't give any money to cancer
which is a bummer but anyway that is the
the FuelBand
and you are going to be reviewing this
in Wired magazine and you coming all
about it there you can also read about
Iran wire.com in the coming weeks right
and if you're lucky you might be able to
get it for $149 on nike's web page 150
bucks yeah it's a little statement yeah
well you know it's kind of right in the
middle fitbit's like a hundred the body
media is over 200 so I bet I bet it'll
be pretty successful yeah I think
they've got a lot of people really
excited for you yeah there's it's
certainly quite the buzz worthy object
around the office something else that
you can't help noticing that you're
wearing or these which are these these
bright white headphones these are 50
Cent's headphones let's take a quick
look at what Curtis AKA 50 cent had to
say about these when we talked to him
earlier this year the sink head says
which is the walkie product for us this
year it has a 40-millimeter driving it
it utilizes play technology a lot of the
wireless headsets UCSC es are utilizing
bluetooth which was originally created
for telecommunication so it compresses
the files and it lowers the actual sound
quality so clear technology allows us to
have the headset 50 feet away from its
source and music without losing CD
quality sound because i've bought
headsets in the past that have been
eacute for hip hop music they had really
heavy bass but not so good sound quality
when you played it with other genres of
music I put on boy equalizer on the sink
headset that allows you to facebook and
for you to skip forward and rewind
actual songs from the actual headset I
wanted to balance it out because the
process of me writing a song or creating
the song sometime I'm inspired by the
production so it's important that for me
to try and have
the general public hear the song the way
I'm actually hearing it in the studio so
here they are these are the new
headphones from fitty cent AKA curtis
the rapper how many pairs of rapper
headphones will be seen now plenty
plenty what like 15 these are actually
kind of cool because their wireless and
the rcd quality audio most of the ones
wireless headphones that we see our
bluetooth so what's this little dongle
you've got on the end of your phone oh
yes couldn't help notice this this large
sort of piece of plastic on top of my
phone this is the wireless transmitter
that transmits the signal from your
sound device plugs in any phone any
laptop whatever to the headphones so
that's better than bluetooth it's it's
better than Bluetooth it uses the clear
standard that's clear que le er which is
it's a licensed technology that a lot of
different headphone manufacturers use
it's a better quality than bluetooth so
it's like CD quality isn't better range
it's a little bit better bluetooth is
around 35 feet clear it they say 50 feet
in our tests we found it to be about 40
feet so it's comparable in range but as
far as portability goes this is actually
pretty good for your clear device
because a lot of them use these sort of
big base stations that are about five
six inches tall you know or to give you
better to give you better range and a
place to reach our to the headphones but
this is remarkably portable and it's
actually one of the best things about it
is how portable they are the only thing
about them that's kind of weird besides
the price they're four hundred dollars
all of the rapper headphones are
overpriced but to his credit 50 cent
does give a portion of the sales to feed
kids in America and gives it to 22 under
underprivileged youths who are suffering
from hunger but the the other thing
about them is that they're you know
they're bright white they're kind of
their kind of gaudy there's a lot of
plastic going on and also when you turn
them on these big s is on the
side blink every six seconds it's a
safety measure for if you're walking at
night right yeah if you walk around at
night not only not only do you have
these giant things on your dome but you
know they're flashing so everybody knows
everybody knows that you're listening to
music and you're listening to them on
really expensive four hundred dollar
headphones and pay no attention to me at
all as I probably also have a smart
phone in my pocket that's beaming it's
crystal clear see me quality audio to my
to my headphones well you could turn off
the flashing if you really want to but
you shouldn't be walking around at night
with these at all anyway but if you're
buying a pair of bright white headphones
you know you didn't you didn't purchase
them to blend in right that's very very
good point anyway you can read the full
review of these headphones which do
sound very good by the way I should
mention that they do sound very good so
for four hundred dollars you are getting
you know better than better than average
audio quality I know there's a version
with a wire as well yes which are three
hundred bucks and we did not test those
but we did test these and you could read
the full review on wired com Terrence
Russell wrote it I believe he gave them
six or seven out of ten he was you know
sort of either way about them I think
the price is a pretty big factor as to
why these didn't fare as well they are
very portable though we should mention
that they banned and you can kind of
crush them and they come in a really
nice carrying case so you can throw them
in your bag and fly with them they're
pretty cool on an airplane anyway that's
all we have for this week and we'll be
back next week with some more news and
some more things to show you from the
gadget lab